افادت مصادر العربيه بان دول عربيه ودول
اخرى اغلقت سفاراتها في العاصمه الافغانيه
كابول وغادرت البلاد على خلفيه تهديدات
امنيه
معنى من كابولا مراسل العربيه عبد الله
نادر عبد الله مع خلفيات هذا الموقف لبعض
الدول وما هي هذه التهديدات
نعم بعض الدول العربيه اغلقت سفاراتها في
كابول وبحسب التقارير
استخباراتيه بان سبب ذلك تهديدات امنيه
وقد اغلقت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
سفارتها في كابول وغادر طاقم السفاره يوم
الخميس الماضي بحسب موظفين افغان في
السفاره السعوديه ولم تعلق حكومه الرياض
وطالبان رسميا بعد على هذا الامر كما ليست
هناك تفاصيل عن هذه الخطه التي اتخذتها
رياض وبشكل عام اغلاق السفارات او تعليق
انشطتها وفعالياتها جراء التهديدات امنيه
امر طبيعي في افغانستان وقد سبق ان علقت
كثير من السفارات فعالياتها وانشطتها ثم
اعادت فتحها يبدو ان اغلاق الرياض
لسفارتها في كابول سوف يكون لوقت محدد
وقصير
وفي وهذا ما هي نوع هذه التهديدات عبد
الله
التهديدات هي التهديدات امنيه
بحسب بعض المصادر من داخل
طالبان بان تهديدات امنيه
موجهه لبعض السفارات لم تفصل هذه
المصادر ان اي من السفارات
توجه الي هذه التحديدات ولكن التهديدات
امنيه وليست تهديدات اخرى
سفارات اخرى في السابق كذلك قد علقت
انشطتها وفعالياتها جراء هذه التهديدات
الامنيه كنت اقول ان اعضاء في طالبان يعني
يتوقعون عوده سفاره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في كابول الى انشطتها الطبيعيه
خلال الايام القليله المقبله كما ورد ان
حكومه طالبان مستعده لتقديم ضمانات
للسعوديه
فتح سفارتها في كابول وليست هناك انباء عن
دول عربيه او اسلاميه اخرى وانها ستحدث
المملكه في اغلاق سفاراتها حتى اللحظه
فيما هل سيؤثر اغلاق المملكه لسفارتها على
الساحه الافغانيه فان للمملكه
بين الدول الاسلاميه والعربيه نعم شكرا
جزيلا يا عبد الله نادر مراسل العربيه من
كابول